[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
es ist Sonntagnacht beinahe schon
Montagmorgen in Rheinland-Pfalz drei
Einsatzwagen der Polizeiinspektion Kusel
sind auf Streife fahren in ihren Autos
durch die Region halten Ausschau nach
Verbrechern doch bisher ist ihre Schicht
ruhig es ist wenig los das Dienst Ende
schon in Sicht bis die Polizisten
plötzlich ein Funkspruch ihrer Kollegen
Alexander K und Jasmin B erreicht sie
fordern Verstärkung nachdem der
Oberkommissar und die Polizeianwärterin
und suche ihrer Patrouille auf dubiose
Personen mit viel Wild im Laderaum
gestoßen sind eine Minute später folgt
der nächste Funkspruch es wird der
letzte sein
[Musik]
Sekunden später sind Jasmin B und
Alexander K Tod
kaltblütlich erschossen von einem
Wilderer der seine Jagd verheimlichen
wollte der Polizisten Mord von Kusel
schockierte ganz Deutschland das
Polizisten in ihrem Dienst am mordet
werden diese Form der Grausamkeit hat es
in Deutschland lange nicht gegeben in
unserer heutigen Folge von Tatort
Deutschland sprechen wir über diesen
eiskalten Mord die unvorstellbare
Motivation dahinter und über zwei
Komplizen die vor Gericht zu Feinden
werden
mein Name ist Mirko Kasimir und ich bin
Stefan Netzeband hallo
es ist Januar 2022
Polizeianwärterin Jasmin B steht kurz
vor dem Ende ihrer Ausbildung nur noch
drei Monate trennen die 24-Jährige vom
Beginn ihrer Karriere als Polizistin
ihre letzte Station ist die
Polizeiinspektion in Kusel eine
Kleinstadt in Rheinland-Pfalz die Grenze
zum Saarland ist nur wenige Kilometer
entfernt einer ihrer Kollegen bei der
Polizeiinspektion ist Alexander K der
29-Jährige ist bereits Oberkommissar hat
eine steile Karriere hingelegt ist
beliebt bei seinen Kollegen in seiner
Freizeit spielt Alexander car Fußball
der 29-Jährige ist Mitglied eine
saarländischen Fußballclubs in der Nacht
vom 30 auf den 31 Januar 2022 sind
Jasmin B und Alexander Kahr gemeinsam
auf Streife
die Einsatzkräfte halten ihre Augen nach
Einbrechern in der Region Kusel offen im
Gegensatz zu ihren Kollegen die mit
einem Polizeiwagen unterwegs sind sitzen
Jasmin B und Alexander K in einem
zivilauto die jungen Polizisten tragen
aber ihre Uniformen und kugelsichere
Westen die vom Hals bis zur Hüfte
reichen als der Morgen anbricht fahren
die beiden auf der K22 eine zweispurige
kurvige Kreisstraße neben der Fahrbahn
erstrecken sich Felder und Wälder wie
kleine Kristalle liegt der Tau auf den
Grashalm es ist ruhig und diese Januar
Nacht ist kalt die Temperatur liegt nur
knapp über dem Gefrierpunkt und während
sich die jungen Polizisten in ihrem
zivil-auto über die Landstraße
schlängeln sitzen zwei Männer in einem
geparkten Transporter in der Dunkelheit
neben der Fahrbahn der Karl 22 und
warten
warten auf Wild die Männer sind auf der
Jagd
illegal auf dem Fahrersitz des
Kastenwagens sitzt der 38-Jährige
Andreas S mit einem Nachtsichtgerät
scannt er die Umgebung entdeckte ein
Tier schießt der aus seinem Transporter
neben ihm sitzt sein Gehilfe Florian V
der 32-Jährige ist selbst kein Jäger er
will aber an schnelles Geld kommen und
hilft dafür Andreas s bei seiner
illegalen Wilderei gegen vier Uhr
morgens entdeckt Andreas es ein
Wildschwein auf dem Feld der Wilderer
hebt sein Gewehr
erschießt es und schickt Florian faul
los es zu holen in diesem Moment liegen
bereits mehr als 20 tote Tiere im
Laderaum seines Kastenwagens alles
weitere was ihr jetzt hören werdet sind
Berichte die im Zuge des Prozesses im
vergangenen Jahr publik wurden wir
möchten euch an diesem Punkt warnen dass
die folgenden Ausführungen sehr brutal
grausam sind
Komplize Florian V gehorcht steigt aus
dem weißen Transporter und läuft zum
Feld auf dem das geschossene Wildschwein
liegt in diesem Moment es ist jetzt kurz
nach 4 Uhr morgens fahren Jasmin B und
Alexander K an den wilderen vorbei die
Polizisten werden auf die Männer
aufmerksam halten an und steigen aus
ihrem Wagen
Jasmin B lässt sich von den Männern ihre
Ausweise zeigen und führt eine
Personenkontrolle bei hindurch Wiese
Polizei Deutsch heißt was die Polizisten
aber nicht wissen bereits in diesem
Moment hat Andreas s seine Waffe unter
dem Mantel versteckt gleichzeitig gibt
der Junge Oberkommissar den ersten
Funkspruch an seine Kollegen ab den ihr
bereits zu Beginn der Folge gehört habt
dubiose Personen mit viel Wild im lade
Raum es ist 4:09 Uhr in ihrer Hand hält
Jasmin B den Ausweis von Andreas S und
seinen Führerschein sie will sich ein
weiteres Dokument Schlägers zeigen
lassen Andreas es behauptet er müsse
dafür zurück zum Auto und geht zurück zu
seinem Transporter aber statt das
angeforderte Dokument zu holen greift
Andreas s nach seiner Schrotflinte und
schießt der jungen Polizeianwärterin ins
Gesicht sofort geht Jasmin zu Boden sie
hat keine Zeit zu reagieren ihre
Dienstwaffe steckt noch im Holz da
voller Panik und den Todesangst gibt
Alexander den nächsten Funkspruch ab
schnell die angewohnten Kollegen werden
später berichten dass sie durch das
Funkgerät einen Schuss hören
der Jäger feuert auf Alexander K die
Kugel trifft ihn am Unterkörper der
Oberkommissar geht hinter seinem
Dienstwagen in Deckung und feuert
mindestens 14 mal auf Andreas es aber in
der dunklen Januar Nacht trifft er nur
den weißen Kastenwagen der Polizist
versucht zu flüchten und rennt aufs Feld
der Jäger nimmt jetzt sein Jagdgewehr
und feiert dreimal auf Alexander kam ein
Schuss trifft den rechten Arm und die
Brust des oberkommissars ein weiterer
seinen Bauch jetzt geht Alexander Karl
zu Boden Andreas es läuft mit seinem
Gewehr in der Hand auf den verletzten
jungen Mann zu als er neben Alexander K
ankommt dreht Andreas es den
Oberkommissar auf den Rücken und schießt
ihn in den Kopf
nachdem das Blutbad beendet ist läuft
Andreas es zurück zu Jasmin B und sucht
nach seinen ausweisen dabei bemerkte
Wilderer dass die 24-Jährige
Polizeianwärterin noch atmet und schießt
ihr erneut in den Kopf die beiden Männer
steigen in den Kastenwagen und fliehen
vom Tatort seinen Personalausweis und
Führerschein lässt Andreas es zurück auf
dem Boden neben mich Jasmin b um 4:32
Uhr 12 Minuten nach dem ersten
Funkspruch erreicht die angeforderte
Verstärkung den Tatort doch die Kollegen
sind zu spät Alexander K und Jasmin B
sind tot
am nächsten Morgen erreicht Deutschland
die Nachricht aus Kusel die Menschen
sind schockiert die Hintergründe zur Tat
völlig unklar und die Täter noch
unbekannt
Bild
und wir beginnen gleich mit grauenvollen
Nachrichten die uns aus dem Landkreis
Kusel in Rheinland-Pfalz erreichen in
der Nacht waren zwei junge Polizeibeamte
dort auf einer Routine mäßigen
Streifenfahrt unterwegs bei einer
Verkehrskontrolle um 24 wurden sie dann
völlig unvermittelt durch Schüsse
tödlich verletzt die genauen
Hintergründe der Tat sind noch unklar
die Polizei fahren jetzt mit Hochdruck
nach den Flüchtenden Tätern und ist am
Tatort mit der Sicherung von Spuren
beschäftigt
stundenlang sich ein Beamter am Tatort
Spuren die K22 ist teilweise abgesperrt
an vielen Stellen des Asphalts und auf
der Wiese sind blaue Markierungen wo
zuvor noch Patronen der abgefolgten
Kugel lagen
Bilder Symbole einer grausamen Nacht am
Nachmittag kommt plötzlich die Wendung
in den Fall keine zwölf Stunden nachdem
die tödlichen Schüsse abgefeuert wurden
veröffentlicht die Polizei ein Foto und
den Klarnamen von Andreas S mit einer
Öffentlichkeitsfahndung sucht sie nach
ihm dass diese Suche so schnell
eingeleitet wird liegt vor allem daran
dass er seine Ausweispapiere am Tatort
liegen gelassen hat
es ist jetzt früher Abend eine
friedliche Straße im saarländischen
Sulzbach weniger Autos fahren hier
entlang die Häuser sind weiß
angestrichen und in einem dieser Häuser
lebt Florian Pfau mit seiner Freundin
und dem gemeinsamen Sohn im Obergeschoss
nach der Tat wie die Ermittlungen zeigen
werden fahren die Männer gemeinsam
dorthin und nehmen im Untergeschoss des
Wohnhauses gemeinsames geschossene Wild
aus dann der Zugriff Einsatzwagen und
Polizisten Fluten plötzlich die Straße
ein spezial-einsatzkommando umstellt das
Haus doch Andreas s erwartet die
Einsatzkräfte bereits über eine Anwältin
meldete er sich vorher bei der Polizei
der Doppelmörder lässt sich
widerstandslos festnehmen schwer
bewaffnete Polizisten bringt den
38-Jährigen der vor wenigen Stunden zwei
ihrer Kollegen kaltblütig erschossen hat
zum Auto bei seiner Festnahme trägt
Andreas s eine blutverschmierte
metzgerschürze
im Anschluss stürmen die Ermittler des
Wohnhaus und nehmen auch Florian v-fest
auch er lässt sich widerstandslos
festnehmen die Polizisten bringen die
Männer zum Haftrichter mit dieser
Festnahme und der eingestellten
Fahndungen beginnen die Menschen immer
mehr die Sinnlosigkeit dieser Tat zu
begreifen zwei tote Polizisten für mehr
als 20 tote Tiere
deutschlandweit trauern Einsatzkräfte um
ihre getöteten Kollegen der Hashtag zwei
von uns geht viral deutsche Polizisten
solidarisieren sich mit den getöteten
Opfern Posten Fotos von Polizeitruppen
die Einheit und Stärke symbolisieren
sollen doch der Schock sitzt tief die
allgegenwärtigen sorgen mit denen die
Polizisten tagtäglich konfrontiert sind
sind plötzlich ganz nah sind
Wirklichkeit geworden am nächsten Tag
gibt es eine große Pressekonferenz die
deutschlandweit live übertragen wird der
Präsident des Polizeipräsidiums Michael
denn e ringt um seine Worte und der
Tränen und mit gebrochener Stimme
erinnert er an seine jungen Kollegen die
große Betroffenheit berührt bei mir
persönlich davon dass ich auch in eine
Tochter hat die im gleichen Alter ist
wie die Verstorbene Kollegin
und darüber hinaus ist es auch so dass
der Verstorbene Kollege mir auch bekannt
war er hat in unserer Pressestelle vor
kurzem ein Praktikum gemacht ein sehr
sympathischer sehr offener Kollege der
für uns auch Werbung gemacht hat das
betrifft einen sehr persönlich wir haben
es ja immer wieder angesprochen aber es
ist wirklich einfach so unfassbar und
unerklärlich wieso hat Andreas S in
dieser Nacht nicht einfach eine Strafe
für Wilderei in Kauf genommen wieso war
seine Lösung und dieser Strafe zu
entgehen eine noch viel viel schlimmere
Straftat zu begehen und zwei unschuldige
junge Menschen zu ermordent ja wirklich
zu exekutieren haben sie wirklich
geglaubt sie würden davon kommen ja das
ist eine berechtigte Frage auch wenn es
wohl keine richtige Antwort darauf geben
wird wollen wir einmal auf die beiden
Täter schauen Schütze Andreas es ist ein
Arbeitsloser Familienvater und
leidenschaftlicher Jäger der immer
wieder wegen letzterem mit dem Gesetz in
Konflikt gerät
so soll Andreas s im Jahr 2004 mit einer
Flinte auf Hasen geschossen und dabei
einen Kameraden mit Schrot getroffen
haben der Jäger wird damals von einem
Gericht wegen fahrlässiger
Körperverletzung verurteilt und verliert
seinen Jagdschein
2012 bekommt er diesen zurück verliert
ihn 2020 aber erneut auch die Erlaubnis
Waffen zu besitzen er überträgt diese
jedoch einfach an seine Ehefrau
hauptberuflich war Andreas s aber
eigentlich Becker mehr als 20
backfilialen betreibt der Familienvater
bis diese Pleite gehen und Andreas es
dadurch insolvent wird und auf 2,4
Millionen Euro Schulden sitzen bleibt
und kurzerhand macht der Saarländer
seine Leidenschaft zu Geld er beginnt
die Wilderei dafür nutzte einfach seine
alten Waffen die eigentlich im Besitz
seiner Ehefrau sind Andreas SS illegales
Geschäft ist durchaus lukrativ bis nach
Frankreich verkauft er sein illegal
geschossenes Wild dort nennt in Exekutor
wegen seiner Art das Wild zu schießen
mit einem Kopfschuss anstatt wie es
eigentlich für Jäger üblich ist auf
Lunge und Herz zu schießen Andreas es
behauptet von sich selbst es sei seine
Spezialität und wie ist der furchtbare
Zufall will gerät Andreas s sogar kurz
vor dem begangenen Doppelmord in einen
Streit mit einem weiteren Jäger wie der
Spiegel berichtet kritisiert diese
Andreas s im Hof eines Metzgers für
seinen jagdstil die Tiere mit dem
Kopfschuss zu töten der empörte Jäger
ist der Vater von Alexander K das
spätere Opfer von Andreas s was für ein
Zufall ehrlich doch wie wir wissen ist
nicht nur Andreas Essen in dieser
verhängnisvollen Nacht am 31 Januar 22
am Tatort sein komplett ist der
drogenabhängige Familienvater Florian v
für jedes Tier das er in Andreas es
Transporter hießt bekommt er 10 € ein
kleiner Zusatzverdienst zu Florian Faust
eigentlich erhaltener Sozialleistung und
so verbringen die Männer über Monate
ihre Nächte gemeinsam beim wildern und
es verbindet die Männer einiges sie sind
pleite
orientierungslose Familienväter und
beide teilen den Hang zur Kriminalität
doch was die Männer maßgeblich
unterscheiden wird ist ihre rätseligkeit
nachdem sie am 31 Januar 22 festgenommen
werden
wir erinnern uns kurz nach der Tat
wissen die Ermittler nicht wer
geschossen hat wer Jasmin B und
Alexander K ermordet hat deshalb sind
erstmal beide Männer tatverdächtig aber
vor den Ermittlern packt Florian V aus
und erzählt detailliert wie diese
verhängnisvolle Januarnacht ablief und
insbesondere wer von den beiden Männern
der Schütze war die Kollegen wollten
mich und den Andreas kontrollieren als
es um den Ausweis ging hat er abgedrückt
sagt Florian V außerdem betont Florian V
immer wieder wie sehr er sich vor
Andreas es fürchtet eiskalt habe er die
beiden Polizisten ermordet außerdem so
die Aussage von Florian V habe er
gedroht seinem Komplizen ähnliches
anzutun
ich habe Angst davor dass er mich
genauso über den Haufen schießt und
Florian Faust Geständnis zahlt sich aus
nach etwas mehr als einem Monat in
Untersuchungshaft wird er entlassen und
der Mordverdacht gegen ihn fallen
gelassen bis zum Prozess ist er ein
freier Mann muss ich jedoch wegen
anderer Delikte vor dem Richter
behaupten Andreas es hingegen bleibt
inhaft im Sommer 2022 fasst ein halbes
Jahr nach dem Polizisten Mord beginnt
der Prozess vor dem Landgericht
Kaiserslautern Andreas S steht als Haupt
Angeklagter als Mörder von Jasmin B und
Alexander K vor Gericht Florian V als
mit Angeklagter aber vor Gericht
streitet Andreas s alles ab und Tisch
dem Richter eine komplett andere
Geschichte auf der Jäger behauptet
Schuld an dem angerichteten Blutbad sei
sein Komplize Florian V denn dieser
hätte zuerst geschossen und Jasmin Bauer
ermordet daraufhin Andreas SS habe op
größer Alexander K das Feuer auf ihn
eröffnet und in seiner Not behauptet
jetzt der Hauptangeklagte habe Andreas
es dann Alexander K wiederum erschossen
nicht wissend dass es sich um einen
Polizisten handelte
monatelang streiten sich die Männer vor
Gericht beziehungsweise Andreas S mit
Florian Faust Anwalt denn sein Komplize
schweigt die meiste Zeit erst knapp vor
Ende des Prozesses sagt Florian Forn
noch mal vor Gericht aus und beschuldigt
Andreas s erneut die beiden Polizisten
kaltblütlich erschossen zu haben nach
fast einem halben Jahr Prozess im
November 2022 spricht der Richter sein
Urteil Florian Faust Aussagen stimmen
mit den Gutachten überein stellte fest
ohne Zweifel war Andreas es der Mörder
des oberkommissars und der
Polizeianwärterin er sei nach dem Motto
Verfahren nachdem er auch beim Töten von
Tieren Verfahren sei Kopfschuss wie
immer so der Richter
Geld verdienen bezeichnet er den Mord an
Jasmin B und Alexander K als eine
Hinrichtung und verurteilt Andreas s zur
Höchststrafe lebenslang mit besonderer
Schwere der Schuld eine Freilassung nach
15 Jahren ist damit ausgeschlossen
außerdem spricht der Richter Florian V
für die Mittäterschaft der
gewerbsmäßigen jagdwilderei und
Strafvereitelung schuldig da der
Komplize jedoch umfassend gestand und
vor Gericht als wichtigster zeugeauftrag
bekommt er keine Gefängnisstrafe
unmittelbar nach dem Urteil liegt
Andreas s Revision beim
Bundesgerichtshof ein am 21 Juli 2023
erkennt das Oberste Gericht dass ihm
auferlegte Urteil aber als rechtskräftig
an Andreas es bleibt also hinter Gittern
und wird dort auch erstmal bleiben
müssen und auch Andreas es Ehefrau wurde
im Zuge eines anderen Prozesses dafür
verurteilt dass sie ihrem Ehemann ihre
Schusswaffen einfach auch so überließ
Straftatbestand Verstoß gegen das
Waffengesetz und Beihilfe zur
gewerbsmäßigen jagdwilderei
Strafmaß 10 Monate auf Bewährung der
Täter ist weggesperrt weitere Beteiligte
verurteilt aber das alles ist nur ein
schwacher Trost für die Familien Freunde
und Kollegen von Alexander count Jasmin
B die Erinnerungen an die schreckliche
Tat müssen allgegenwärtig für Sie sein
aber die Region und die Polizei tun viel
um Alexander K und Jasmin B in Ehren zu
halten
im rheinland-pfälzischen Büchenbeuren
ist eine Gedenkstätte für im Dienst
getötete Polizisten errichtet diese
wurde bereits 2018 eingeweiht das man
mal ist ein fast drei Meter hoher Stein
umringt von 10 Basaltblöcken zum
Innehalten und zum erinnern
zur Eröffnung waren hier bereits 45
Bronze täglichen angebracht 45
Bronzetafeln mit Namen geburts- und
Todestagen der Verstorbenen
Einsatzkräfte
inzwischen mussten hier zwei weitere
Bronzetafeln angebracht werden für
Jasmin B und Alexander K
das war unsere heutige Folge von Tatort
Deutschland bei Fragen Anmerkung oder
Feedback schickt uns gerne eine Mail
unter anderem vielleicht an
podcast@bild.de oder auf unseren social
media channels alle Infos dazu findet
ihr übrigens in den Show Notes unsere
Quellen sind Artikel aus dem Spiegel SWR
Focus und von Bild Skript Lilly von der
Osten Redaktion Stefan Netzeband
Postproduktion weight watch Studios
München wir hören uns beim nächsten mal
alles Gute euer Stefan und eure Mirko
macht's gut ciao